[Musique]
dans le cadre verdoyant du jardin de
l'état le département accueilli la 4e
édition de la journée sans alcool le
samedi 30 octobre un événement organisé
par la fédération régionale
d'addictologie de la réunion présidée
par le dr mythes et les associations et
structures qui lutte contre les
conduites addictives et les
comportements à risque chez les jeunes
alors le message qu'on souhaite c'est
que c'est possible de passer le passé
des journées sans alcool voilà c'est
possible de s'abstenir de consommer de
l'alcool et c'est même fortement indiqué
pour la pour la santé aujourd'hui de
pouvoir pendant plusieurs jours dans la
semaine s'abstenir de consommer de
l'alcool au-delà de cette journée sans
alcool nous c'est un appel aussi de
sociétal de d'attirer l'attention de la
population sur la problématique alcool à
la réunion où la réunion est l'une des
premières régions les plus touchées en
france avec avec près de 450 morts par
an donc ce qu'on souhaite c'est une
évolution de la législation pour de la
réglementation pour davantage protéger
la population du risque de l'alcool et
notamment des jeunes aujourd'hui qui
sont vraiment aussi l'objet de notes ce
rassemblement de protéger les jeunes
puisque les addictions sa console ça
commence dans 80% des cas avant 18 ans
les dispositifs mis en oeuvre par le
département tout au long de l'année dans
ces pmi dans les points infos conseils
santé de la collectivité ou encore le
soutien à la formation des travailleurs
sociaux sont cités en exemple nous
accueillons aujourd'hui la journée de la
prévention au sein de ce site
emblématique du jardin de l'état qui
appartient au département c'est une
façon concrète de dire nous met la main
ensemble on est ensemble l'union fait la
force dans ce combat extrêmement
compliqué à mener et nous avons une
action forte qui est menée déjà depuis
quelques années en matière de lutte
contre les addictions
l'exemple le plus visible c'est le plan
de communication entier addiction que
nous avons menées refuse resist qui
parle aux jeunes qui a été lancée il ya
plus d'un an maintenant et à travers les
médias que ce soit le numérique que soit
le bli journaux écrits mais surtout les
publicités à la télé partout on a fait
de la pub anti alcool anti addiction et
on a utilisé le langage des jeunes pour
une meilleure prise de conscience de la
situation un événement marqué par le
village de la prévention réunissant les
partenaires et par le défilé jusqu'à la
préfecture où une motion a été déposé
[Musique]